[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link it's time for another
conversation with someone interesting
from the internet and this week at the
roundtable of dim lighting we have
Natalie Tran technically she wasn't at
the round table of dim lighting we
caught up with her at VidCon it wasn't
that dim and it wasn't round it was
rectangular it was a squarish
rectangular ish table but we took these
microphones so it shouldn't sound that
much different right
although that's really beside the PIA
Natalie has been making videos under the
handle community channel since 2006 so
going way back but she's been making
videos consistently pretty much on a
weekly basis especially recently again
all showcasing her unique sense of humor
her channel currently has over 1.5
million subscribers she's the second
most viewed Australian channel with over
500 million views now the majority of
her videos are this combination of
stream-of-consciousness monologues with
a sketch format where she plays every
single character a little taste of that
we're gonna give you right now a 2009
video called sexy underscore baby those
embarrassing old email addresses with
5.5 million views hi
so do you guys have make up stupid email
addresses when you were young I know I
did it's incredibly embarrassing when
you're still using them I can't ever
look Natalie sorry sweetie could you
also give me your email address again I
can't quite make it out so it's s sx c
aces sx c and underscore and then he's
got a baby baby yeah yeah and then
Hey and GTL okay Angelina numbers here
669 so we have s X L like sexy sexy
underscore braids the underscore angel
69 and hotmail comm that's you you
wouldn't think it would you great now I
could you just take a sense I'll be
right with you thank you okay you
probably already get a sense if you're
not familiar with their content of why
she's popular she's totally relatable
and that's the thing I've always thought
about Natalie's videos is I always
immediately relate to the observational
humor that she's that you know the thing
that she's making an observation about
and it's always funny and she's been
doing this for a very long time and her
fan base has remained and continued to
grow I mean she goes back to you know
we're talking oh seven oh eight early
stages no oh six oh six all the way back
all the way back to the beginning
certainly so I mean it's a testimony to
her ability to remain true to a voice
and continue to captivate an audience
but we had an interesting conversation
with Natalie I mean it was different
than I expected I would say don't lean
you expected to right I mean for someone
with such a developed comedic voice and
such longevity on the platform she was
extremely humble almost mink yeah I mean
I do believe that she helps set the
template for popular comedic vlogging on
YouTube today I mean just look at
superwoman as if not a direct emulation
of her certainly an inspiration through
a couple of layers of YouTube since 2006
leads to someone a phenomenon like
superwoman who we've also talked to on
ear biscuits but when we're talking to
Natalie it was almost like we had to
convince her of that in the conversation
that she made a legitimate contribution
to the medium you know she didn't want
to own it and and says it's as if she
hadn't even thought about it
right and this is coming from you know
two guys who are definitely have we have
a lot of aspirations and we see this
YouTube thing as the thing that we want
to do and continue to expand and
everyone that we talked to on air
biscuits typically
they have that kind of focus it's just
like yeah I found this thing I have
found success on YouTube and I'm gonna
keep pushing it and interestingly I mean
obviously she's just as talented as
anybody that we've talked to but her
perspective is totally different it
seems like YouTube is a side project
yeah I mean that was surprised and not a
career that I mean that's at one point
she actually said she feels very lost
that comes up in the conversation I mean
it's an interesting case study
it's like she's evolved on another
continent I mean yes she's on another
continent but it is an island yeah I
wonder how much that has to do with it
it's like she's she's kind of in her own
world of developing as an artist that is
not tied to playing the YouTube game as
we call it or even making it a career I
mean she talks about the things that she
wants to do while this is her side
project that surprised me right and we
say all that to prepare you for the
conversation because I feel like there
are moments in this conversation where
it feels like we're pushing her we are
pushing her to get an answer for her to
recognize how awesome she is and so yeah
this is gonna be interesting it's gonna
be a near biscuit that stands on its own
that's different from the ones that
we've done so far we want to prepare you
for it we think it's great and like link
said I think it's an interesting case
study and someone who thinks very
differently about the whole online
career thing here it is our ear biscuit
with Natalie Tran
[Music]
what is the thing on your wrist this is
like a pedometer in a heart rate monitor
and I wear it because I like to know how
many calories a hundred percent that I
can consume so if it says you've exerted
this many I make sure that I eat that
amount does it know when you're eating
or do you think tell me I don't mean
that I try it like I just mean cuz I
often eat over this way I always kind of
try and justify how much food I'm eating
if that makes sense so I got you this
far so I can definitely eat food right
you can put like a hamburger in terms of
steps are you sure it's not a watch
because it looks like a watch also watch
I hold it
how convenient how's your steps are you
uh I mean you're obviously physically
fit no no I'm really I've got mr.
Burns's body if you take who's mr. burns
from The Simpsons
oh come on a link I've never seen that I
think that shows only in Australia yes
it is an Australian show it's very small
yeah I'm sorry I didn't get you
reference they're coming out with a new
cup called the vessel and this is a this
is a cup that you poured any liquid in
the world into the cup in it like any
other Cup it analyzes what you have
poured into the cup and tells you how
many calories it is so it'll be like a
blue Gatorade 300 calories I mean you
made I talk to you I'm auditioning to be
the voice of the vessel but no good for
us last year this is happening it is it
exists and it will be on the market so
you can put anything you want any mix
and it knows well that's a great
question I was told that the guy tested
it poured a bunch of different liquids
into it and it got everyone right now is
this just a Kickstarter campaign where
people promise everything and nothing
really happened though this is legit I
read it well I think the question is
though I mean you anyone who has a
contraption like this that you're
wearing is a little bit progressive in
terms of technology right I'll be
completely upfront with you I was given
this and then but
I was so infatuated with it I bought him
one full price and for me that's the big
deal of you like a product when you're
given one and then you buy someone else
one so I have to be upfront with you I
was given one I wasn't told I had to
wear it but because i'ma lose I was like
I'm gonna wear this everywhere and then
I got him one him being I'm sorry him
being my partner Owen because I really
wanted to see how much we collect
daughter at the end of the day so you
can also measure the percentage of your
sleep how often you stayed still and so
I check every night I wake up and I'm
like eighty-three percent what about you
why does it change anything about your
your habits change is what I know about
my habits what kind of sleep are you you
move around a lot not apparently not I
think it's because we're in a hotel at
the moment and the dinners are very
heavy so I'm just stuck on to them the
word the water soon is that the covers
yeah sure she sleeps she sleeps in a
room with sand dunes yeah you're
sleeping on piles of there is no sand in
my room no you know what I mean the big
the dinners yeah you know we call them
do days or comforters or whatever yeah
yeah yeah do they're like trapping you
you're trapped in your bed it's very
heavy when you're just kind of keeps you
still so you're not a health conscious
person are you but are you so it's more
of a competition between the two of you
to see who can yeah yeah I've worked the
most ER eat the most
yeah we're just very we're big into our
data collection so for example we had
traditional heart rate monitors which
you know the ones you stick around you
your body those are uncomfortable so I
wall them we wore them for a full 24
hours so we for a few days so that we
could compare echo exertion after a few
days but I now have like a permanent
scar under here because just if I was
such like a dick I just didn't take it
off I was like oh it's really hurting
under there how is this eight years ago
and now I have like these permanent like
nipples and like nipple looking scars on
Days really so you have four nipples I
have four nipple that's told me how am i
hot right it was worth it no it seems
pretty obvious to translate four nipples
into like internet success yes so young
when you're in this field of occupation
does that happen is it okay I'm gonna
turn have you turned the heart rate
monitor scars or any of these other
weird gadget tree things into vlogs
I can't believe I even told you guys you
haven't made a video card I have four
nipples because use views caps for
exclamation points naked in the title no
I haven't told anyone about you know
it's interesting that we that we're
talking about this taking something like
four nipples and turning it into it if
you're not gonna do it we're gonna do it
okay because we technically do have four
nipples shoot it would be a big letdown
there four nipples and it's just the two
of us guys but you have even from the
early days kind of made a decision it I
think to just kind of do things your way
right so you eat - not necessarily play
the YouTube game even we're just gonna
say that because I'm failing okay like
your early videos right yeah there's a
couple of videos in your first like ten
or twenty videos where you would be like
boring video mm-hmm and but you mean you
were like you were trying to be ironic
would say that yeah because you were
doing what you did called your
housekeeping videos early on yeah so
were you answer questions in that kind
of yeah and so you were like boring
video but I definitely got the sensation
that she's telling me it's a boring
video because she thinks that guys this
is gonna be a boring video not because
I'm trying to be some super ironic
person to trick you into watching it
just a certain honest cool level yeah no
it was just honest the only way that was
YouTube yonks ago and I guess every it
was just such a different community and
I guess I don't know yeah and it that
seems to be that that's the kind of
that's how your career has been
characterized as you're just you just
being yourself you just doing your thing
I mean it literally is you multiple
times in these video yeah no I guess I'd
never it never started as anything and
I've always kind of hoped that I'd just
keep it up for fun and continue with
life and it's just something I guess it
was thrown into the mix right now I like
to call you the queen of split-screen
there's lots of people who will do that
you're shaking your head but I cut off
all my fingers and lastly I didn't
notice it's in the crop and they're like
you're missing all these pink
it's a hazards of split-screen the
physical split-screen is not what I'm in
awe of I know how to do that so I know
how to not cut my fingers off there's no
you just don't cross the line
so you're not blowing my mind there but
I call you the queen of split screen
because the comedic timing how do you
maintain and execute the comedy that
you've come up with in your head or
written down or you I don't know you
tell me how you've do you write it down
and then how do you how do you maintain
the comedic timing in a split screen
with yourself
oh my video is a scripted so they're all
scripted and I guess especially with the
sketch kind of skip parts of them they
all have to be scripted because they
interact with each other it breaks my
heart that I'm not good enough or
patient enough to do any green screen
because that would be much more
interesting but um I guess I just I put
a 20 cent coin on the floor and I'm like
that's where the other person standing
or sometimes my cat moves it and I'm
like I wish you hadn't done the other
presence ending but it's very high-tech
I just put a coin on the floor well you
put a coin in I didn't even know existed
I mean so yeah even even a 20 cent coin
is something that I know I make a coin
and then I put it on the floor and then
I I look at that pot and I go I hope
this looks right right so you establish
tiling that way but are you are you
hearing in your mind the other you
speaking the retorts
and how do you know how long it's going
to take yeah this I have this really I
must be very boring and repetitive
because I have this awful ability to
speak at the same pace of sentence as
constantly so like sometimes I've dubbed
things and it's just worked the first
time I'm like wow like I just have no
variance in the way I speak
meaning you ADR it yet to match your
references you just say it is so you're
not listening back to the I what I
thought you would have done is like okay
I'm gonna play back baby yeah with the
videos sorry not with the videos but I
mean sometimes that's right but back
with your videos when you're doing the
split-screen thing you're not like going
back and watching what you just said
because you can't really touch the
camera other than right because just
gotta stay in the same place and the
light always changes now I always just
in my head I can hear it so it's okay
but if you notice in my videos I not a
lot the other character nods a lot or
they kind of look in the other direction
just in case if I if the 20 cent coins
moved I just kind of look off I nod
allied like this like I close my eyes
and I nod so that way there's no real
interest right it just kind of works
yeah and how critical are you of your
own videos do you watch them back and
having done them for almost eight years
eh do you watch back your latest video
even beyond the edit like once it's up
and are you critical or do you shy away
from that and B do you go back and watch
some of the earliest videos does that
ever happen
um I make a lot of videos that don't go
up as I'm sure everyone does so after
I've added if I really don't like a
video I watched a few times if I think
it's bad sometimes I think maybe I'm
just in a bad mood I'll come back later
if I still don't like it it doesn't go
up how often does that happen it used to
happen a lot more often but maybe I'm
sleazier now but I'd say maybe one in
every four videos every three or four
videos doesn't make it up really yeah I
write a lot I write a lot more scripts
that don't make it up as well so every
script so it might be something that
happens in them in the middle of
shooting and you're like oh this just
doesn't work in or I used to give up but
Rowan who helps me film a lot encourages
me to finish them and then I finish them
and edit them and see how it goes but
maybe I'm just being a dick and I often
don't like so I don't you don't put them
up we I think we just have a lower
standard you know video is a super
polish I don't know what you took well I
put the production value that you guys
were I would be very happy with every
video - I'd be like no this is going up
because I paid people it's going my
pajama is like it's okay I'll come back
to the budgets but it's like we get to a
point we're just like well we've
definitely we definitely our videos that
we're not proud of but they looked and
you're like ok but we've got to put this
but put this up but you get to a point
where you're just like nope
if there's not a video because at this
point are you still is it still kind of
weekly or what like what's the yeah I
still do them weekly I mean don't get me
wrong I still put ones up that I'm not
super happy with but that tends to be
when I go well I've got work I just
and I tell people I'll have one up a
week now I try to write and so if if it
worse comes to worse I do put one up but
yeah it's not always something I'm super
happy with well I'll tell you I'll tell
you something that maybe we decided we
weren't going to tell anybody but I'll
be vulnerable and I'll expect a
reciprocation later on in this air
biscuit okay but yeah we've definitely
put a lot of work in time and it's
difficult to walk away from something
but I mean we had an idea for something
and it involved kids and then we shot
the whole thing and then we realized
that inadvertently it had gotten way too
close to something that the fine
brothers were doing yeah and you know
then being so successful at it we didn't
want to come close I mean and they're
also friends we didn't want to come
close to any sort of comparison so we
scrapped the whole thing and when we're
talking two days of filming with kids
like lots of kids I'm telling you and we
just didn't anticipate how close it was
gonna hit the final product was going to
seem and we scrapped the whole thing
that's a shame and that's it's really
not only are you spending money and
you've got all these people working on
this thing but we had all these kids
lined up then we had that well somebody
had to tell him we didn't hi it someone
else it wasn't gonna see the light to
their videos not being put up on YouTube
but I'm gonna find a good way to handle
that I think here's what we should do we
should just give that video to the fine
brothers and let them make that video
I'm sorry to hear that I'm sure that if
you put it up they wouldn't have seen it
that way and I'm sure other people
wouldn't know if you've got a big bank
of work and they wouldn't have well I
appreciate that you want to that you're
that you're encouraging us but no we're
not yeah and we shouldn't have so hey
we've been there Wow very recently no
thanks for bringing it up I feel
horrible now so okay so you you are part
of what I would call the first early
wave of YouTube you know 2006 let's
let's go back in and lead up to that
point what got you into YouTube and that
kind of thing so let's just go back to
the beginning of Natalee okay so where'd
you grow up and what's that story um I
grew
in Sydney with my family as you do
sometimes I don't know I grew up with my
family as you do I was just a very
normal child I'm the youngest which
probably says I was a bit of ish but I
think that's about it really like I was
you know the youngest youngest is how
many of to my sisters nine years my
senior nine years yeah I wish I crashed
the party layup yeah it is a huge gap so
what how do your parents explain that
I'm Asian so we don't even speak of such
things oh really
so tell us about your parents oh they're
lovely my father he was a teacher in
Vietnam and he came to Australia he
taught primary school in Vietnam I mean
in Australia and then my mother was a
solicitor in Vietnam she came to
Australia and she worked a few jobs and
eventually worked at a post office like
sorting mail and stuff in the back room
so what was the circumstances that led
to the move from Vietnam to Australian
when was that they fled Vietnam and they
arrived led yeah they arrived via boat
in 1981 so okay so explain the fleeing
part yes so after the war a lot of
Vietnamese people seeked refuge other
places and they were lucky enough to
have arrived in Australia when laws were
better and we were accepting me and they
arrived in Australia in 1981 and we've
been in Australian since so I was born
in Australia so yeah I I read a quote
where you said that your parents endured
so much to give you and your sister
great lives yes I didn't they were
wonderful very selfless people and I'll
always being indebted to them are they
still living yeah they are okay one day
I'll buy them a massive house and that's
the plan that's the plan I'm gonna buy
them a massive farm and anything they
want and well you know you have a very
specific sense of humor that we both
really appreciate laughing and it's very
developed and it's great did that come
from your parents yeah my parents very
much made me very aware of like the
subtle differences between people I
guess in the way the behave not
necessarily where they wasn't really
always the same kind of observational
humor that I talked about but it may
have just been have you noticed this or
have you noticed that and I guess
something that you pick up or maybe it's
just a different but I mean
observational humor isn't really a
specific thing everyone notices it so
well to be able to put it in a certain
way especially in the way that you're
able to write it is absolutely a gift
yeah I guess our curiosity is is that
the type of thing that came up
conversationally with friends or with
your family I think my parents probably
established that way of thought but it's
probably something that I talk about
with friends or it's just something I
noticed as everyone does when they're
hanging out with friends you seem to say
that culturally that your parents you
didn't really talk to your parents about
the specifics of anything you know
you're talking about the difference
between you and your sister being born
is something you never discuss with them
no sometimes I go sometimes I go to
other people's family times I can't
believe the way they were allowed to
talk to their families like if I laughed
too loudly but didn't tables mom like
calm down as I've gotten older she's
being a little bit cooler with things
like I can say words like you look sexy
and she laughs but it's still a bit you
know she's calmed down a bit in terms of
me being a bit of a dick around it's
like I see her and she's always in her
pajamas because pajama is the home of
tire of immigrants at home all the time
and like sometimes I come over and
because I'm coming over I'm in proper
clothes you know and she won't know I'm
coming up this she'll be in her fluro
pajamas that she bought for $3 at the
markets or something and I'll come over
I'll slap her on the bummer you look
really sexy back in the day she probably
would I would have been in a lot of
trouble for that
but now she's okay with it a little so
now you started making videos and for
years a few years at least you were
making it from home like we live in with
your parents yes I made them might they
bought me my first computer when I was
at uni and I made them through my eye
side so I literally like dragged my
computer everywhere I read about lonely
girl in the newspapers and I remember
just going on to the website being
really interested in the website did you
think that lonely girl was a real person
no I didn't which is why I heard about
in the paper it was after everything had
been no prevailed it was just I had
never heard of YouTube which I love the
idea of a university person not knowing
what YouTube is because if you think
about it now every man and his dog knows
what it is but I remember going on and
really enjoying the community and then I
saw video responses so I started
clicking on videos
and then that kind of landed me into a
space where I saw everyone communicating
with each other and I wanted to do the
same
so you made video responses to lonely
girl more to videos across YouTube yeah
just two other videos instead but did
you have a channel at a time called
community channel when you're doing that
yeah so when I saw hate the name
commuter but yeah I signed up it's like
calling yourself HBO or something it's
really like you know it's like that um
y-yeah so what point is that you know do
you know it's called public is it called
public access television here it's like
YouTube so we had that in Australia and
I was obsessed with this channel because
you would see people filming like a
science showing their living room and
then the telephone would go off and
they'd look at the camera right look at
the hallway and I'd be like oh and then
you know he'd say I'm just gonna get the
phone I'll edit this out no I won't and
then he went out and you just hear this
conversation happening so I really liked
this channel so I called myself communal
okay it's like a television it's like me
I didn't think you know okay so you're
saying specifically the there was an
Australian public access that was called
community change that's called community
so you just rip their name yeah I just
called myself like HBO but it's not HBO
it's funny because you know I would
assume that most people just are like
this this girl had this amazing insight
into the community of YouTube so she
people think I'm religious and they're
like oh so you're like a do-gooder
because you like the community and the
channel don't like no I just like these
it's like the equivalent of calling your
chant your channel public access TV
it's exactly like okay it was really
dumb ironically it does have this it
seems like you were getting involved as
a community member
yeah with the whole the conversation
because it seems like that's that's
where I thought you were going with the
name of the channel because what got you
involved originally wasn't the this
impetus to entertain but it was to be
involved in a conversation like that
stories I'm gonna go with that from now
on I originally caught myself
commissioned cuz I went in there with
the sense of community there you go then
to entertain I like it take it that's
the new story we just officially changed
the official story like that okay did
you
have a need to socialize on the internet
was there did you not have friends in
real life and was this kind of a I'm not
gonna lie I mean I went to uni and I
worked after uni so it was like I came
home after like you know you come home
at 10 o'clock at night so I kind of made
videos at nighttime and then I like I
had friends man back up friends okay
I'll back off but not really but did you
make actual YouTube friends early on
absolutely a lot of really wonderful
people that I've met I've met online and
it's yeah it's lucky well do you do you
keep in touch with these people now like
some of the earliest people yeah I went
to one's wedding before and I have a
wonderful time with with people who made
online okay so you were at university
but you were still living at home of
your parents yeah and so 10 o'clock
you'd log on to the youtubes and you
would make your response videos at some
point I imagine it it started to shift
into more of your comedic voice how did
that happen I mean I guess back then
like you could everyone took I still
take feedback you know to help I guess
when people really enjoy one element of
your video good okay well maybe I'll
focus on that and obviously they enjoyed
some storytelling then okay I'll just
keep going with that in terms of the
genre with it's sort of a vlog with
these scripted elements right were there
other people doing that kind of thing
like did you like emulating some yeah um
I remember the reason that I started
even doing the cloning was because a
subscriber made a video response to me
and he did the same thing and then I did
one back to him and then that just kind
of everyone enjoyed that and then I just
kept going but then I figured it was
easier just to break it up between
monologue and sketches to the story tell
I guess and then what what became what
really started to break out for you what
was the turning point from just I'm
doing this for the fun of it to whoa
people are writing articles about me it
was very organic I mean I've got a -
sorry I don't mean it's an oily but I've
got 1.5 million subscribers you know
kids log on these days start a YouTube
and I can YouTube account in six months
they have like five million subscribers
or something
mine's been a very slow organic growth
it's not been this meteoric rise but by
2010 I mean articles will be written and
they were speculating about how much
money you were making millions of
dollars that I make and they were saying
they were seeing I mean they were saying
okay and that she's the queen of YouTube
she's in the top 10 earners I don't know
how that came out
in that year it was really weird I was
I'm definitely not in the top ten er I
think well that's what everyone on the
list said yeah right but the fact that
you were one of those 10 people at that
point where you make it you were making
it into a career look I still work
outside of YouTube and I still do stuff
and I guess I don't know I guess it's
like I said it's been so slow and so
organic I've always just accepted it
that it's something fun I do on the side
that is a bit bigger but I mean
especially with going to VidCon today I
just and you see how huge it is for
everyone else that's I mean that's I
think it's a different playing field for
those guys and maybe for me it's just
something really fun I do on the side
that was made my transition from being a
young adults to someone in their late
twenties made that a bit more exciting
if that makes sense I mean I get the
sense as you talk about it I mean
there's a that you kind of want it to be
that way too I mean it would you say
that you're like this is this is a great
medium this is fun for me this is a
great outlet but this isn't something
that I necessarily want it to propel me
to a place where I'm you know I've got a
television show or I'm run my own studio
or that kind of thing it sounds like
those aren't necessarily things that you
aspire to yeah I would love writing as
I'm sure everyone who's on YouTube will
tell you I you know I love writing and I
love creating things and I'd love to do
other things and explore it in other
mediums but I guess I always try and
remember I was doing something before
YouTube came along if that makes sense
and I want to make sure it doesn't take
me off the path entirely okay so what
what was that yeah I don't have a path
necessarily but I don't want it to
completely drive what I'm doing so what
what is what have you been doing since
University that this is kind of still
been the side project what's been the
main thing I'm very lost like every
person in the first world is who is very
privileged and you know well too many
choices but I
I mean I I feel like the way that you
characterize it you sell yourself short
I mean it's just like you know we're
sitting here yeah
we've been fans of yours for a long time
and then we we see you at VidCon we're
like we definitely want to talk to
Natalie because we have this level of
respect for what you've what you've done
and how it's just it's so pinpointed and
so like so good and been good for a very
very long time but see but you shake
your head you're like oh no you guys
know all the time every time I go and do
work with an agency or something they
always pull up things you guys have done
they always say this is kind of the
caliber we want I'm like what you guys
attack the stray lian's it's not going
to happen
but um you guys are amazing and I well
but I mean I we may have some bells and
whistles and we're doing a different a
different type of video but you know in
terms of the I guess I guess what I'm
saying is that the the core elements
that make something engaging and good on
YouTube are things that are based in
personality and just the ability to
entertain people and that doesn't
necessarily have to include some looks
like I wasn't saying what you did was
good because of you no no I didn't mean
it know what I'm saying but I'm saying
the core of what you have is you know
I'm either production companies out
there who would bend over backwards to
say hey we want to take the stuff that
because anybody can add that kind of
stuff right but they can't bring the
personality in the connectivity that you
have with your audience they can't bring
that to that's what they're looking for
right well I would say the comedic voice
I mean I think this is an interesting
conversation it's kind of turned into us
trying to convince you that you're great
seriously I mean it's you know our
assumption was okay she's a full-time
youtuber she's been doing this all these
years and I'm very interested in the
resilience it takes to remain relevant
for eight years with changing what you
do very little
I think we're surprised to hear a level
of humility that you don't eat I don't
know if it's that you don't want this to
be your thing or that you just don't
consider yourself of a caliber that you
for it to be your thing I think that's
what I'm trying to figure out I don't
know what I'm gonna be doing but I don't
know I guess I have other things outside
of YouTube as well that I'd really like
to achieve in life so tell me about
those things I want to build a place for
my family I'd like to give them
somewhere nice and I guess I'm just
working towards that at the moment so I
can can do that for them well what is
your what is your perception as someone
who's who's been involved in the
community for you know a long time and
you've seen the evolution of YouTube and
then you see like you say you come to
VidCon it's been mind-blowing I can't
even explain how am I'm going so what
are some of the things that you've
thought as you've observed it
we've likened the crowds running towards
people like World War Z it has been who
I don't even know what they're running
towards I just I just assumed there's a
good-looking young boy on the other side
of it some that's reddish in nature
there must be a really tall young
good-looking guy on the other side or a
very pretty good like beauty girl on the
other side because they just scream and
they run and I mean I remember like the
days where I would sit on stickam in my
lunch breaks I would walk down to this
is so embarrassed I would walk to the
internet cafe around the corner from my
work and I was sitting there so I could
talk to the other America like to the
American youtubers during my lunch break
and we would do that and I remember that
so I remember like Phil DeFranco was in
there and the wine cone and all these
are you know and so I remember that was
what it was like like that's what
YouTube was like for me so when you come
hearing that whoa oh there's a sign and
it's printed in color and I was like
it's pretty money you know okay and then
I went into the registration room on my
own badges and like barcodes this is
getting pretty right yeah so that's it's
changed a lot from what I what it was
and I guess I'm so it's amazing I love I
love the things that get shared on
YouTube it's incredible and I love that
people can access video production at
such small cost RIT like speak like
relatively speaking to what they were
before you know that kids with SLRs can
make films it's incredible right but
yeah at the same time it's like you know
I definitely especially as somebody like
we've been to every VidCon just because
we've been here you know so it'd be
great to go but but
you you yeah it's even VidCon itself has
changed so much from the first year till
now you definitely get this sense it's
like hmm this has become it's amazing
but there are these there are these like
trappings of this has become something
that's so much it gets the more popular
it gets in a more celebrity that there
is involved in and it kind of gets
tainted right I had this I think this is
because I look really boring so as we
were coming through this woman saw me
his mother came up to me she said you
work for VidCon I don't work for me she
was anyway let me tell you we're really
upset and she went through and I've had
a lot of parents I must be someone who
parents approach because I've had a lot
of parents come up to me today
and they tell me I'm just eating a
sandwich and like listen I have to tell
you I'm really upset because I felt in
my heart braces like I drove you know I
flew my kids here from Florida and we
didn't get to see some and so you know
like the signings they closed off the
signings whatever and for me that's an
interesting thing because I guess as it
but you're right and I guess that comes
along with this whole new wave of what a
celebrity is and how there's this Fame
attached to these guys and they have to
like security escorting people is really
interesting you know and I understand
it's necessary but that's been an
interesting shift in culture I guess
that it's not so much a connection
anymore now it's you can come and ya
have signings and do you how do you guys
I'm surprised you guys are on this level
like you that you haven't made harassed
well we stay in here a lot honestly and
we're not young cheeky British I don't
even know what cheeky means but I think
it means that you get smart I've already
pictured him in my head but yeah we we
have to stay in here a lot there is a
sense when when it does have Lee we've
got our scheduled you know signing that
is gonna be for a certain number of
hours or whatever and some people will
probably be turned away from that yeah
and then when we're walking through if
we're doing something and we're going to
a panel and we say sorry just come to
the thing tomorrow and to think that if
those people couldn't get into it it is
this there's this dynamic that I told
link I was like might the worst part of
VidCon tip for me is are those
interactions where I'm telling somebody
know
I can't get a picture or I can't do it
get a hug right now because if I do then
maybe there'll be another one in another
one and another one and we're not even
that you know like link said we're not
the 20 year old British we're not that
boy block anywhere near the most popular
people here certainly you guys I mean do
you do you feel like that this is kind
of eye-opening that you've been isolated
you've you've continued to contribute
through your channel and it's been very
consistent I mean in terms of the number
of views it's not like you've dropped
off that much but do you feel like
you're living in an older YouTube that
your eyes are being open being here kind
of a thing yeah in Australia it's so
different like it's we live in a country
where if you know there's arguments
about whether we should have faster into
it or not like we live in a very
different kind of place and when people
say mean the straight or something they
say hi genuinely spit takes me a while
to know where I know them from because
they're so relaxed and they're so hey
how's it going and then I assume I must
have met them through work or something
and then I say yeah and so it's very
relaxed and it's very different I can't
imagine this kind of screaming like it's
it's very yeah
do you watch other youtubers today and
what do you think I still see I'm I'm I
stick to a lot of people who have been
watching for a long time I do get
recommended a lot of young people but I
guess as you do when you start to be
precious like I said and you think your
time for all the time with workers there
we go I'll watch these later I'll watch
these later but I'm on holidays at the
moment so I'll catch up more but um I
think you catch do you catch glimpses of
other youtubers doing what you've been
doing for eight years and what do you
think when you see someone like
superwoman doing the split-screen and
she's playing different characters and
talking to herself I mean you say you
know oh that's me that's she's doing my
thing she would I do but I mean will you
tell me what you think I'll tell you
what I think I understand having that
kind of a feeling but that's not like I
made up split screen and I think kids
these days are very polished or what
they do and I think they're really smart
and switched on and you know good and
good on them
but they wouldn't be I mean there's a
argument to be made they wouldn't be
doing if you hadn't done it first I mean
in terms of somebody would have done it
it's not like you know what I mean like
I did like I said everyone's been doing
splits great it's not like that not that
specifically but even the comedic voice
and female with a strong comedic voice
all alone playing different characters
or speaking her mind in a comedic way
and interacting with fans it is said it
you set a template that absolutely is
being emulated directly and indirectly
and through a couple of different layers
at this point and being around and still
doing it I mean does that give you a
sense of satisfaction I don't never
attribute their videos to me I don't
have a goal they've obviously like taken
this from me but okay look I just you
just have to be like good on them and
they they're so good at what they do now
you know like it took me so long to
figure out maybe I should move off a web
camera maybe I should get a microphone
and maybe I shouldn't you know I just
they're great at what they do and you
just have to applaud them really so you
don't want to say that it took you so
long and it doesn't take them as long
because of me and other people because I
think that's the truth no because it's a
generational thing everything will
happen faster with the next generation
everything will it takes you it took me
longer to look up books in the library I
know now kids have all these new ways of
you know it's just the way time works
and you have to accept it move on you
made a comment Rhett read it to me about
how you put comments at the end of your
videos and now there's people who do
that and do more with comments what did
you read that that's on your about
section of your channel oh is that sound
like it must have been a joke I thought
I deleted that dick joke okay oh that
was a joke cuz me being a dick I thought
I deleted that I don't channel takes me
ages to get it around my channel well I
definitely took it as sarcasm yeah but
yeah I but at the same time ice I sense
that there's there's truth under under
that which is like yeah I was you know
everyone's doing all this interesting
stuff with with commas I only put that
up because I got comments um I think
which is like oh she does this like so
and so and then you go on there's like
14 year old doing it
that's all so I was like I did it you
know I've been doing it a while it's
okay
I was obnoxious and I thought I had
delay did not apologize that I hadn't I
don't think you should apologize
it's just I liked it no I thought I had
deleted it but I can never they changed
that YouTube page they do change it
quite a bit yeah that's just everyone
like I said if I didn't do it someone
else is gonna do it I didn't invent
comment feedback or anything I just
ringing dude I'm sorry but when you put
like porn music with it
can you say that you invented that come
on well no one's copied that so that's a
baby that's not the magic maybe that's
not that I thought it was you've you've
been more consistent in making your
videos over the past year yeah but there
were times when you would kind of fall
off and be gone secret babies was there
anything let us in on some of these
secret babies was there what took you
off of youtube and where there was there
any drama I mean I guess my hunch or my
guess is that when you're putting
yourself out there and you're you are
setting a template for a strong voice
female vlogger
that I have to believe that there's this
gray line between your personal life and
your public entertainment life yeah did
that have an impact on your ability to
maintain your videos did anything go
wrong I like to think no I mean I know I
talk about things my mother doesn't stop
but they're pretty generic things you
know my mother tells me to bring a jump
but everyone's mom tells them to bring a
jump us or a sweater right yeah
like that you know I like to think I
actually don't talk about my personal
life too much really like they're all
very generic don't you hate it when this
happens
that it happens to everybody if that
makes sense there's not really that much
about my personal life in there but fans
demand it I mean there's speculation all
over the internet about you being
engaged a few years ago because you wore
a ring on the wrong finger or something
I wear many rings how many raise um look
it's all just yeah one it one the first
break I had I can't remember why it just
happens and I don't know about you guys
but sometimes I'm a very I I work myself
up sometimes I don't
because I've made a big gap the next
video needs to be really good and then
just becomes this huge fear there's a
stupid fear and I don't know why so that
usually is what prolongs a big gap the
second I remember I had just gotten back
from a big trip around the world we
created a video a travel series Rowan
film there's with me a travel series as
well as our YouTube mmm and we were
contracted to make one a week as well as
that while we travel there was a lot of
content to make especially when you're
on the ground and you're traveling and
it means no sleep ever it wasn't on your
channel notice I put on somebody else's
on a company's channel and by the time I
got back I was just exhausted and I'd
gone through a bad time with my personal
life and I just wanted I guess to get
over that cuz like I said I mean
YouTube's really fun and stuff but it's
on the side and I always try and make
sure life is good first right before
YouTube yeah so so I you know every
every youtuber deals with it with just
fans that take things too far and
messages and you can get berated with
comments and messages that kind of thing
and from our experience that females
deal with this many degrees more
impregnate you so I mean like how what
how has that been has that had any
impact on the way that you approach
YouTube um yeah look if I could go back
I mean no I shouldn't say that it's it's
hard because on the internet for some
reason if you wear a singlet top it it
somehow is very you know erotic whereas
if you were to walk down a street in a
singlet top it's not very interesting or
you know in anything like that but um
you you just grow a thicker skin to what
I guess sometimes I don't I don't tend
to go out in public meetings a lot to be
completely honest with you because I do
receive I used to receive what I was I
used to receive a lot more kind of
threats and scary emails and stuff like
that and I what do you mean um I just
you just had to have liked it I reckon a
dozen people who would write me every
day and they would span over years so
man when the first bid can't happen I
really wanted to go and I was
going but then the emails got scarier
and I guess because they knew where I
was coming and then they would say I
know where you're coming and twelve
people who you would get 12 emails a day
for a year at least from 12 people and I
remember one guys all independently just
yeah yeah I remember one guy got really
upset and he wrote me every minute one
night and it was insane and you get that
a lot as a girl that I as a woman sorry
I think that um I'm sure everyone gets
that sorry I just think sometimes with
anything people just get a little bit
confused and perhaps a project feelings
that don't necessarily exist so how did
you deal with that I mean what I just
said I'm really sorry I can't come to
fit correspond to the people the
stalkers these are stalkers right I mean
it's to be honest now I don't even know
if I get them you know I mean you just
don't read them after a while but didn't
know that then so perhaps I just paid
too much attention to them and I should
have just let them go was it the type of
thing you had to call the police I
called the cops once because a few times
but I remember one time I was really
upset because someone left a package
outside my house and it obviously
happened in a very short break where I
had left my house to walk down the road
for something so I assumed they were in
my street waiting because it had no
postage stamps or anything like that and
I called the cops but back then again no
one really watched YouTube said the cops
too said to me you know well get over it
yeah don't go on the internet then what
did they open the box oh yeah so we open
the box and there was just weird stuff
in it he looked I want to know what the
weird stuff was your glasses and all
those weird things you wrote to me no it
was um it was just a letter that he'd
written from the perspective of like my
fish and he'd given me stuff to put my
room and stuff like that
and I look I know it came they were it
was good intentions just right in the
wrong way that's just somebody doesn't
understand boundaries yeah who was
around the block which is scary and then
the cops didn't do anything no they said
if he hurts you then we can do something
like that's
if you hurt me I'll let you know Thanks
thank you did it get worse how did that
how does that we restore resolve I know
nothing happened and this is the thing
as I should have just learned from him I
should have just been smarter from
younger and just realized you just
ignore things well but you know I can't
help but think that you know if you
think if you take us for example I mean
first of all being guys that you just
naturally don't have to deal with those
things as much it's not it's it's not at
the same degree and then I think that
there's there's two of us right so but
if you if you if you change a couple of
those factors and there's there's more
of that kind of thing you're you kind of
by yourself you it's not like you're
sharing the channel with somebody I mean
I know how that would affect me
personally is I would I would lose some
of my motivation to kind of be like okay
yeah I really I want to keep doing this
and I want to keep raising my profile
because well I'm gonna get more crazy
people like this that are trying to
reach out to me you know what I mean if
that's if that's part of the package I
could see how that would cause you to
lose a little bit of a taste for you
know YouTube fame yeah well look look
like I shouldn't have made you know I
was in my bedroom I was making videos
and I I created a very intimate setting
I probably should have been more aware
of that and I'm sure you guys receive I
mean it's all girls screaming out there
at VidCon I'm sure you guys have
received your fashion girls are as crazy
as guys yeah yeah like I'm gonna go in
your house and wear clothes girl's touch
everything that's scary too well you're
just making me very thankful that well I
haven't read any of those we don't
they're in your bedrooms right now you
know I'm just saying it's girls around
the hallways right now you don't mean I
think I'm sure you guys a subject to
that somewhat but you know not to the
same degree so as usually you say you've
got things that you want to try off of
YouTube YouTube has changed dramatically
you know over the past eight years your
content has definitely gotten you know
more polished that kind of thing like
you said as you've you've added just
from a technical perspective it's it's
gotten you
is changed and gotten better but it was
always great in terms of the content and
you seems like you're continuing to kind
of pump it out like what is the what's
the long-term plan with with YouTube I
don't know I'm really worried because
I'm hitting 30 soon and I'm really
worried because I make these little
girls like I watch you know but you must
be 11 like this is not good this is not
good no I don't know I guess I just keep
doing it till I have a lot more videos
that don't make it than do and then I
just stop doing other things at the same
time right so like you did this you shot
this series which that what that was for
a brand it went somewhere else somewhere
else was it I was for Lonely Planet so
we did and around the world travel
series and we're trying to do one now
but it's bit harder ironically
independently because we don't have a
brand attached to us even though we
produced the whole series anyway so
we've had a lot of trouble with just
tourism boards kind of getting back to
us and just because of what we learnt it
was so hard to get content to feel 2
minutes when you don't know anything
about a city yeah so we would land in a
city would go we have two days to film
here mm-hmm
and that's quite hard so we've been
trying to talk to you and board about
organizing itineraries but they don't
necessarily want to collaborate with
YouTube but I understand they must get a
billion requests a day from bloggers and
and one but that's the flavor of the
type of projects that you're working on
at the moment so we run a few companies
we do like corporate videos and we also
make we make wedding videos as well oh
yeah that's what my favorite things and
that's what we do that takes a we just
finished wedding season and in Australia
so and I work freelance doing other
things it's also a freelance it sounds
like you you you like to be involved in
the creative process and in this kind of
medium but it isn't necessarily that all
your efforts are focused towards the
personality Natalie centered content
that YouTube YouTube is all about that
right it's just personality driven but
you're saying I want to make videos I
want to be creative I want to write but
I don't necessarily have have this
aspiration to be like no but I want to
funnel all that creativity into you know
your channel to continue to grow that I
just don't have I don't have what it
takes I don't think it seems to be a lot
of 8 I totally understand
a lot of effort I know a lot of people
don't especially in traditional media
when I hear interviews with youtubers I
know how much effort goes into a YouTube
channel I know how much effort goes into
you know the community and God you go
into a company and they have a whole
person dedicated to running the Facebook
page so I understand how much effort
goes into a YouTube channel I don't have
that kind of motivation or dedication so
I don't think I could carry it off but
um yeah I just don't have that
dedication well but but I think kind of
what we've kind of arrived at is that
it's uh it's definitely not a an ability
issue you don't have that specific
desire that would lead to that that
would lead to this is the only thing
that you do and this is like your 100%
all-in there's nothing wrong with that I
mean it's not you I mean I'm not being
accused of anything it's very much just
it's interesting I think honestly
refreshing you know to talk to somebody
who that isn't there a very specific
aspiration I just don't know how
everyone does it like I'm trying to
organize I'm like some t-shirts and
stuff and my brain just melts when they
write back an email that's more than a
paragraph and I'm oh my god there's
words in here and fulfillment and
clothes come back to three months of
times well want you know one of our
dreams is to come to Australia so maybe
you can help us answer the questions
that you have when we come there so no
you should definitely go to assert
whereabouts what you want to go we
wanted we'd want to do like a four or
ifer are a four by four adventure you
know how biggest rally is right like
it's big yeah it's big a lot of 4x4
adventures are happening there oh that
would be wonderful when were you doing
it I'm committing you do whenever you
book us do you have a do you have a
four-wheel drive vehicle I I have a
three door car and what happened to the
fourth door it no it's like one of those
really small Mazda's it's not gonna make
it across the outback it has back yeah
is that what it is a two-door hatchback
yeah and I make everyone wait when they
want to get in the back seat and I push
the seat forward no way you can hump in
well we can work we can
transportation I can hire a car though
okay I got my full license this year a
hire car for you guys it's gotta have
like really but we die we don't have any
plans but we do want we are at some
point I don't know how many months or
years it will be but we're gonna we're
gonna come to a strike you must be
making content all the time like you
might I mean we're really busy but it
yeah it's just something like that just
we'll take just a lot of things that
fall into place but we're gonna do it
it's gonna happen may I ask if you're
booked out like do you create content in
advance like are you oh I mean we try to
you know get our rhett and Link channel
stuff lined up and then good mythical
morning you know we just have to keep
churning those out you know it's daily
show type things yeah I'm asked do you
get tired creating so much content yeah
I mean there's a mentality that like
you've started this this train right and
it's and it's got this momentum and
sometimes you just find that you're just
exclusively committed to just keeping
the train going right I mean we're able
to encourage each other and we're doing
enough different things that you know we
don't have to just do the one thing so
that helps us out a lot and we let our
ideas drive us a lot and we have you
know we have the freedom on the red link
channel to do anything we want which is
really great we're grateful for that so
that helps yes there's not any at this
point there's no real there's no real
sense of burnout or anything like that
even with all the content that we create
but there is like man this is tough and
it never stops yeah I was gonna ask
about that because like obviously I just
take breaks whenever I want but how do
you deal with having to this is the
thing with YouTube and the Internet
right there's no seasons
yeah it just continues and how do you
guys deal with that kind of well we used
to break up good mythical morning and we
still do break up good mythical morning
in two seasons but the breaks in between
seasons I've gotten to do something like
this one between season five and six is
a week yeah that's what it mean like how
do you that's not yeah you really don't
you don't break yeah the answer the
question is well we don't because once
people make this you know make our show
a part of their daily routine you're
like well I don't want to stop because
then I'll stop making it a part of their
daily routine but we
can do it from Australia so we'll figure
out how to make yeah that's right it's a
full day to fly to Australia that's a
day you won't be able to make one yeah
we can shoot ahead of time we can make
it happen well listen we'll we'll take
our Australian epic trip offline that's
what they say in the corporate world but
keep doing what you do and thanks for
hanging out with us
[Music]
and there you have it our ear biscuit
with NAT Tran I feel like I'm colour net
that travelled it now that we've had the
ear biscuit you know is on that with a G
or just net in a tea
oh just no G that face you're like
there's a G and NAT I was thinking oh no
I literally I put it everywhere except
at the beginning of the words but it
before you saw the wheels turning like
NAT G like a silent in the yet I got it
I got net that was a net joke okay you
know I feel like I have two seemingly
contradictory thoughts in my head at the
same time and when this happens I like
to stop and recognize it okay because I
feel like these are the special moments
in life linked when you have two
contradictory thoughts in your head
about Natalie sure about G net okay on
the one hand it's refreshing very
refreshing to talk to someone who is
just kind of like guys I am NOT going to
take your bait yeah and yeah and say
that I want to be the super successful
entertainer that you guys want me to be
that's the one thought and then the
second thought is a frustration with her
mm-hmm because she is so awesome she's
an incredible unique voice and it I her
sense of her Sensibility and her sense
of humor and her writing style and all
that I can see it so easily expanded
into other formats you know beyond what
she's doing is great but I could see it
expand in so many different places and
as a producer
the producer Amin as a pretty fan wants
to see it come to life and blossom into
what it could be and so I'm like what
but I don't want to I'm I'm not one to
force you into that so it's refreshing
and I want to like you know I'm kind of
envious on once in one hand but then I'm
frustrated on the right right yeah I can
relate to that I feel refreshed that
after you know eight years of YouTube
content its she's it's still it's still
an out it's still a creative outlet for
her it hasn't become a job I mean maybe
there maybe it's not evolving on another
continent maybe that's trying to
oversimplify like the analysis of our
super youtuber maybe it's more of a
personality type um you know that she's
you know she says I don't it makes my
mind melt to think about merchandising
it's she doesn't think that way but she
the way she does think is very comedic
Lee and insightful and you know we can
just we can just revel in that and be
happy that hey she's doing this as an
Ellen she's got other things going on
too that we don't necessarily get to see
but it rounds out who she is as a person
why do we have to see all of it and that
be her career but yeah as a producer in
as a fan I'm like well if if she was a
couple of blocks from here well I'd love
to work together yeah on a you know on a
frequent basis and just tap into that
comedic psyche that she's got yeah yeah
and maybe the verb is exploited and I
think maybe that's what she's sensitive
to and but I don't know yeah I think
that arrays abound yeah it's it remains
to be seen I think that my analysis of
the situation is that part of it is the
fact that she is just not as enamored
with you know she kind of knows in some
sense what it would be like to be even
bigger than she is right now and it's
not something that interests her but I
hope that it's not that she that she
feels like she needs to apologize for
her success or that she doesn't deserve
it because that's the last thing that's
true because she definitely
deserves it she's a unique talent and we
were happy to have a conversation with
her and we're gonna keep watching her
content yeah and you let her know what
you think of her on her Twitter you know
hashtag her up I you know what I don't
think you should hashtag I think you
should use the @ symbol you can hashtag
ear biscuits but then at natalie tran
tagged her up
hashtag your business that work now let
natalie tran know what you think hey you
know what it is he could do hashtag
Ginette i mean you could do that i can
start that to also leave us a review on
iTunes and just just keep listening you
know we value that and we value you
these ear biscuits are baked for you not
for nobody
yeah because we unabashedly and
unashamedly want more and more people to
listen to this oh we wanted well I just
said I want them to keep listening
yeah well and more new people say no you
guys please get your other people to the
last thing you're gonna accuse me of is
being apologetic about more people
listening I'm just being honest with you
and on that note will they have another
one next week we will
[Music]
[Music]